[Applause]
foreign football for the first time in
their history
being successful on the pitch absolutely
strengthens our eco
message
because it's
it gives us credibility in the eyes of
football fans
this is forest green rovers un certified
as carbon neutral and described by fifa
as the world's greenest football club
the mission became about reaching sports
fans people are passionate about a
particular sport in our case football
and making them fans of the environment
as well and we've seen that work our
ethics and sustainability we brought
them here to the club
our fans come here they see what we do
they go home and they start to change
how they live
football has an added kind of
opportunity which i think is a
responsibility to use its platform to
influence people
thanks in large part to their owner
these minnows of the english game are
proving to have an outsized influence
the season just passed saw the team play
in the fourth division that's about 70
teams below the likes of giants
manchester city and liverpool but the
team are on track for promotion to
league one something never achieved in
the club's 133 year history
and it could have an even greater impact
thanks to the club's leadership in
fighting the climate crisis
[Music]
based in the west of the country forest
green rovers has become something of a
passion project for the man often
described as a green energy
industrialist
when i got here in august 2010 the club
had 13 players that was it
part time never trained on a full-size
pitch so i helped them out i thought why
not club was 120 years old big part of
its local community at the end of the
summer they said you need to be in
charge you need to be the chairman i was
like well i don't i'm not really busy
but they made it clear it was that where
the club would fold and so
i thought about it and thought well you
know
how hard can it be i'll just i'll just
run the football club but i didn't think
beyond that i didn't think about
anything
[Music]
vince is an outlier when it comes to
business leaders let alone the owner of
a sports team
dropping out of school he joined a new
age traveller community where he
tinkered with trucks to get by
in 1985 he was caught up in the battle
of the bean field an assault by british
police on travellers heading towards
stonehenge
by the early 90s he'd built a small
windmill on his van
connected it to power lights and a water
pump and found himself on a hill above
nailsworth the home of forest green
rovers
because i had a windmill on the roof of
my trailer i knew it was a windy spot
because you're in touch with those
things when your energy comes from the
wind you've got batteries you've got
meters you see it come in you see it go
out you know you're in tune with what
you use and where it comes from so i
knew it was a windy hill and then i just
had this idea that i could spend another
10 years living this low impact
lifestyle myself or i could drop back in
try and build a big windmill so
i decided to do the second one
vince started a wind energy business
called ecotricity
its success turned him into a
multi-millionaire and was instrumental
in establishing renewable power in the
uk's energy mix i mean wind energy
wasn't even one percent in britain
at that point and what are we now
renewable energy combined about 40 and
most of that is wind energy
transforming the energy landscape was
the priority
but vince was becoming conscious that
creating a more sustainable uk would
require more holistic change in our
daily lives i know jeremy clarkson i
want to be clear about that but i am a
bit of a petrol head and i'm a tree
hugger as well i spend my life building
windmills and fighting climate change
driving fast cars
what am i going to do about it it's a
big contradiction it can't all be
sandals and lentils can it he went about
building the uk's first electric vehicle
charging network
more people would buy electric cars if
there were more places to charge up and
and people would build more charging
points if more people bought electric
cars so that we thought we'd jump in
build a national network and try and get
the whole thing going
then he helped build an electric sports
car the nemesis
since then he started a vegan food
company and even produces diamonds made
with carbon captured from the atmosphere
i got into energy in the 90s because the
way the energy was made in britain back
then was the biggest single source of
carbon emissions from burning fossil
fuels this is where the mission now
comes from because we found that
transport was the second biggest and
food was the third and between them the
80 of everybody's personal carbon
footprint and that rule also applies to
a football club of any size a business a
whole country basically
and it was food that started the changes
at forest green rovers day one here of
being in charge of the football club i
bumped into my first thing we were
serving a beef lasagna to our players
and
i sat down immediately with the with the
sheriff and the manager and said we
can't do this you know so we took red
meat off our menu on day one of being in
charge
we upset some people and we said look
try our food this is why we do it by the
way we didn't just do it we explained
why and if you don't like what we serve
here just bring your own we don't mind
you know
i'm not vegan or vegetarian but i don't
mind not eating meat when i'm here
and i think quite a few people have
recognized that you know they can eat
meat any other time of the day or the
week
why not try vegan food and then be
pleasantly surprised that they enjoy it
in the
old days you'd go up and you get a cup
of coffee and somebody would say uh you
know do you want some of this and
pull out a hit flask and you think
you know i'm quite sure and they brought
milk into the stadium they brought cow's
milk into the stage
so those changes were quite hard i think
and then and i think some of the fan
base moved away from the club as a
consequence of that
but um we we've introduced a whole new
set of uh supporters and followers who
who really like what the club stand for
now
you know food sales have gone through
the roof the crowd
growth has been phenomenal as well
and all of these were things that people
plenty of people said wouldn't happen
they said you know people won't come to
a game if they do they won't eat they'll
bankrupt the club all this kind of stuff
you know so plenty of skepticism but i
didn't ever doubt it would work actually
i didn't really care either because i
couldn't run a football club that broke
all of the the rules that i lived by you
know the the things that i believe in i
couldn't do that um and i'd rather
walked away but i didn't i did it
instead look where we are
to earn the title of the world's
greenest football club fgr have done
much more than just change the menu
the stadium is solely powered by green
energy
the pitch itself is organic free from
pesticides and weed killer fed by
seaweed and captured rainwater
it's also cut with a solar powered mobot
for electric car drivers they can charge
up during the game
i think it permeates to to a huge level
it's um it's a little bit of thinking
out of the box it's uh just trying to
think about things in a different sort
of way not the thing not the way it's
always been done well it's just a
passion that i have you know um to
to see us get to a place where we live
in a more sustainable way we're not
wasting stuff not polluting stuff not
wiping out nature and not causing the
climate crisis
the players and staff can eat what they
want but when at work training or match
day there's only vegan food served
wingback kane wilson the league's player
of the season is one of an increasing
number of professional athletes who are
turning away from meat
i had an injury tendinitis which is like
a an injury um it was inflammatory it's
like it was in my it was in my knee and
i was struggling i tried everything to
get rid of this injury i couldn't i
couldn't shake it and it was costing me
it cost me money because i wasn't
playing so i had to kind of try and find
a way to get rid of it
i was going to go for an operation i was
thinking of all different options and
i just seen an athlete in america
talking about how he had suffered from
it and changed his diet and
he had gone so i said well that's what
i've got to do i mean it worked for me
hands down
a large number of high-profile athletes
extol the benefits of going vegan from
sports as diverse as tennis basketball
ultra marathon racing and even
bodybuilding
some at forest green are convinced their
vegan-only food rule might be
contributing to their recent success
the team hasn't dropped out of the top
three places all season
so does playing for the world's greenest
club change anything for a player you
probably just rewires you a little bit
in terms of maybe things that you wasn't
as conscious of before do i mean it's
everything i mean is everything involved
with foreign screen i didn't even know
it was possible for a t-shirt to made
out of coffee i mean i'm not i didn't
know that was a thing
what's perhaps most remarkable is how
far the forest green ethos reaches
far beyond the few thousand people of
local village nailsworth
welcome to the heavens devils podcast a
forest green rovers podcast by two
americans who have no idea what they're
talking about yeah so we were brought in
by the vegan and green aspects of the
club uh it matched our personal ethics
and so
once we found this club that that is
doing so much good off the pitch and
we're like we're gonna give our money
and our time to a team let's do it to a
team that matters that matters just like
the clash we're the only band that
matters for us fgr the only club that
matters
nathan and cheyenne have made it over
from the us for a critical game in
forest green rovers industry
it's the end of april 2022 and with four
games to go of the season a draw away at
bristol rovers would secure promotion to
the league above promotion that's all i
want one point i'll do
true to form the greenest club in the
world arrives on an electric bus
something the club hopes to make a
permanent fixture next season
dale is in relaxed mood
happy to see a vegan pie on another
club's menu
[Music]
how often do you see that
oh you know what it's quite common
it's amazing we went carlisle a few
months ago and there are two kinds of
people
leading the way for the majority of the
season forest green
it's played in low and except wide
wilson into 87 henry's shot brilliantly
stopped by bell shaw
forest green have had some big
opportunities
how is this game still nil nil
rovers wants a free kick
but it's full time
and it's joyous scenes for forest green
rovers
a goalless draw is enough to send the
team up a division the highest they've
ever climbed in their 133 year history
today belongs to forest green rovers
[Applause]
before securing promotion forest green
estimated they had over 100
international fan groups
but it's not just down to what the
players have achieved on the pitch we
did a media survey recently in the last
12 months the the global impact of
forest green rovers on in all forms of
media was five billion impressions right
and that was a league two football club
so i would say you know we're we have a
global reach
and
that's a good thing in league one we'll
just have a bigger global reach
[Music]
that reach doesn't just elevate the
green message it's good for business too
more fans generally means more shirt
sales and more pay-per-view streams
but crucially for a small club like
forrest green it's the ability to
compete in the big leagues
and that comes from sponsorship
businesses are adopting green things
products services whatever it is and are
looking for places to advertise
themselves and to sponsor
and we find ourselves here as a very
visible you know greenest club in the
world kind of stuff and so we've
naturally attracted a lot of sponsors in
the last couple of years that other
clubs at our level won't get don't get
purpose is the most important thing
right as a business or a football club
we have to make money to exist um but we
don't exist to make money right it's
like the old question do you live to eat
or do you eat to live we only eat to
live if you exist to make money then
you'll take the hard-nosed business
approach you'll hurt the environment
around you the people around you because
you're chasing money above everything
else so we don't do that we have a
different purpose i just don't think
actually there ever has to be a conflict
between the environment and
economics and ethics actually i think we
can have all three
with promotion to the third tier of
english football secured forest green's
journey has entered a new phase the club
is soon to start building a larger
stadium the world's first made all from
timber
eco park even includes a green tech hub
for local business
whatever project dale vince pursues
there's usually an element of activism
especially when it comes to tackling the
climate crisis
back in march campaigners interrupted
premier league games in the just stop
oil protests it turns out vince had
accidentally funded it the need to stop
oil transcend sport it transcends
motorways you know transcends everything
they reached that said that we want to
start a new campaign really helps with a
bit of cash and i did what they didn't
say to me was that they were planning to
disrupt football matches
which which i find amusing
it's direct action that sets vince and
forest green rovers apart removing meat
and single-use plastics from sale using
renewable energy
other sports teams even some of the
biggest have been recognized for their
work on reducing their environmental
impact but like plenty of businesses
nowadays many are accused of trying to
assuage any guilt forming in more
eco-conscious fans and simply not doing
enough a portion of every red sox ticket
will be contributed to the aspiration
planet protection fund which will use
carbon credits to offset fenway
emissions
ultimately vince has found sport to be a
powerful element of communication in
challenging the status quo of the
climate challenge
in his own football team he doesn't just
reach his direct community but all those
that come into contact with it whether
at home or abroad
from supporting the conservation of the
ocean to flying the palestinian flag on
match day forest green rovers has an
identity like no other club
something that's hard to come by in the
world of modern day sport
and while fgr might be unique
other clubs are taking note
there's a pump laying outside the front
of our ground now that's on its way to
port vale soon uh because we had a
conversation about car charging and they
want some advice and we actually had
some old hardware so we said we'll give
you a charger um that was before they
beat exit for us on the last day of the
season
which won us the league
have you embraced veganism yet no i
haven't no no i don't tell dale forgot
you